.
STILL MORE TO COME.
>> YES, HE'S BEEN PAYING CLOSE
ATTENTION TO EVERYTHING.
>>> WE ARE LEARNING HOW HIGH
PROFILE RACIAL TENSIONS AFFECT
BLACK AMERICANS.
BLACK AMERICANS REPORTED POORER
MENTAL HEALTH WHEN TWO
ANTI-BLACK EVENTS OCCURRED.
THE WHITE AMERICANS' MENTAL
HEALTH WAS NOT SIGNIFICANTLY
IMPACTED.
WIZDOM POWELL IS A PROFESSOR AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF CONNECTICUT.
GOOD MORNING.
IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU.
>> GOOD MORNING.
>> THERE'S A LITTLE BIT OF A
DELAY, WE'LL HAVE TO WORK WITH
THAT.
BUT I THINK THIS IS A GOOD TIME
TO HAVE YOU HERE, I THINK
YESTERDAY, DURING THE CLOSING
ARGUMENTS, THAT TAPE WAS PLAYED
OF GEORGE FLOYD'S DEATH.
THE BEFORE, THE AFTER AND THE
DURING, THAT I THINK HAS BEEN
VERY TRIGGERING FOR A LOT OF
PEOPLE.
AND ONE PERSON SAID TO ME, NOT
ONLY IS THAT TRIGGERING, BUT THE
DEFENSE, IN TRYING TO EXPLAIN
IT, IS ALSO BEEN TRIGGERING TO
DEFEND THAT KIND OF BEHAVI.
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO THAT?
>> I ABSOLUTELY AGREE.
THE THING ABOUT RACISM IN
GENERAL IS THAT IT IS A
BIO-CYCLE SOCIAL STRESSOR.
AND INCIDENTS LIKE BEING IN A
COURTROOM AND REPEATING THE
EXPOSURE TO THOSE 8 MINUTES AND
46 SECOND.
AND NOW WE KNOW NOW 9 MINUTES OF
GEORGE FLOYD'S DEMISE CAN BE
TRIGGERING FOR EVERYONE WHO IS
EXPOSED TO IT.
AND SO, THERE IS A CONSEQUENCE
OF HAVING THAT BE REPLAYED IN AN
OPEN COURT.
>> YOU SAY, WIZDOM, THAT WE PASS
ON TRAUMA FROM GENERATION TO
GENERATION.
WHAT DO YOU MEAN?
>> SO, YOU KNOW, THERE'S NEW
EVIDENCE TO SUGGEST THAT NOT
ONLY DO WE TRANSMIT THE WAY THAT
WE COPE WITH STRESS AND TRAUMA
ACROSS GENERATIONS, BUT THAT WE
ACTUALLY EMBODY THAT STRESS
GENETICALLY.
AND THAT WE CAN PASS THAT ON IN
OUR DNA TO OUR THOSE IN
SUBSEQUENT GENERATIONS.
BUT HERE'S THE OTHER PART OF IT.
WHAT IT REALLY MEANS IS THAT IF
WE DON'T DO THE HEALING WORK,
THE RACIAL HEALING WORK NOW,
THAT GENERATIONS, OUR CHILDREN,
THEIR CHILDREN'S CHILDREN, AND
THEIR CHILDREN WILL HAVE TO DO
THE EMOTIONAL WORK.
>> AND, YOU KNOW, I HAD A
FRIEND, I HAVE TO TELL YOU, I AM
SURPRISED AT MYSELF AT HOW
DEEPLY THIS HAS AFFECTED ME.
I THINK THAT YOU KEEP SO MUCH
IN, AND THEN YOU START TALKING
ABOUT IT, AND BEFORE YOU KNOW,
THE FLOODGATES ARE OPEN.
I HAD A WHITE FRIEND OF MINE
SAY, HOW DO YOU FEEL?
I GO, NOT SO GOOD.
BETTER QUESTION IS HOW DO YOU
FEEL?
SO WHAT ROLE DO YOU THINK WHITE
PEOPLE SHOULD BE PLAYING AT THIS
TIME?
>> SO, FIRST OF ALL, I THINK WE
ALL HAVE HAD OUR BREATHS
COLLECTIVELY STOLEN BY THE
INCIDENTS OF RACIAL VIOLENCE
THAT WE'RE ALL BEARING WITNESS
TO VIRTUALLY AND DIRECTLY FOR
THOSE WHO ARE ACTUALLY ON SCENE
DURING THE TRAGIC EVENT.
SO, I WOULD SAY THAT WHAT YOU
CAN DO NOW, IF YOU'RE REALLY
WANTING TO RISE UP TO MEET
BLACK, INDIGENOUS AND PEOPLE OF
COLOR IN THIS MOMENT IS TO ACT
IN TRUE ALLYSHIP.
LISTEN WITH A THIRD EAR.
ACCEPT THE REALITY AND TRUTH OF
WHAT PEOPLE ARE EXPERIENCING
WITHOUT REQUIRING THEM TO
EXPLAIN AWAY OR TO OFFER
ADDITIONAL CONTEXT FOR WHAT
THEY'RE FEELING.
BELIEVE PEOPLE WHEN THEY TELL
YOU THEY'RE HURTING THE FIRST
TIME.
THAT KIND OF RESPONSE LEGI
E
LEGITIMATING THE WOUNDS THAT
WE'RE EXPERIENCING CAN GO A LONG
WAY IN PROMOTING RACIAL UNITY,
HEALING AND RESTORATIVE JUSTICE.
>> I KNOW SO MANY ADULTS ARE
STRUGGLING AT THIS TIME.
I CAN'T IMAGINE WHAT IT'S DOING
TO CHILDREN.
WHAT IS THE CONVERSATION THAT
PARENTS SHOULD BE HAVING WITH
THEIR CHILDREN, BOTH BLACK AND
WHITE?
>> I REALLY APPRECIATE THIS
QUESTION.
BECAUSE I THINK THAT ONE OF THE
THINGS WE HAVE FORGOTTEN ABOUT
IN THIS MOMENT IS THE IMPACT OF
THESE EVENTS ON OUR CHILDREN.
AND I WOULD SAY THAT EACH PARENT
HAS TO SELECT A METHOD OF
TALKING TO THEIR CHILDREN THAT
RESONATES WITH THE TEMPERAMENT,
THE DISTRESSED TOLERANCE, THE
EMOTIONAL CAPACITY OF THAT
CHILD.
EVERY CHILD IS DIFFERENT IN
THEIR TOLERANCE FOR ADJUSTING OR
RESPONDING TO THESE MOMENTS.
BUT HERE'S THE THING.
WE CANNOT -- YOU KNOW, BE VAGUE
ABOUT EVENTS THAT ARE HAPPENING
NOW WITH OUR CHILDREN.
WE HAVE TO TALK TO THEM
TRUTHFULLY, WITH AGE-APPROPRIATE
TERMS.
BUT RECOGNIZING THAT OUR
CHILDREN ARE ALREADY
EXPERIENCING IT.
SO, WE CAN'T HIDE THE TRUTHS OF
WHAT WE'RE EXPERIENCING IN THIS
MOMENT FROM THEM.
BE DIRECT.
BE AGE APPROPRIATE.
BE LOVING.
AND MOST OF ALL, LISTEN WITH A
FERVENT EAR.
NOT ONLY WHAT THE CHILDREN ARE
SAYING BUT HOW THEY'RE
EXTERNALIZING OR BEHAVING IN
THIS MOMENT.
>> YES, THAT'S RIGHT.
WIZDOM POWELL, WE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME.
MAY I SAY YOUR NAME SUITS YOU
VERY MUCH.
IF YOU OR SOMEONE IS SEEKING
MENTAL HEALTH RESOURCES YOU CAN
CALL THE HELP LINE,
800-950-6264.
OR IN A CRISIS, PLEASE DETECTIVE
NAMI TO 741741.
LET'S GO BACK TO ATHROWN AN